[Music]
here's your money briefing for Monday
May 15th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
as the fight over the debt ceiling
continues in Washington the spotlight
has shifted to what missing the deadline
might mean for the nation's 66 million
Social Security recipients wsj
retirement reporter Anne terguson joins
us to discuss what retirees can expect
so Anne help us understand some of the
language here what is the debt ceiling
and why do we hear about efforts to
raise it from time to time the debt
ceiling is it's currently 31.4 trillion
dollars and it's the legal limit on how
much the government can borrow to pay
its bills is something that Congress
sets and then periodically when they
need to borrow more they have to to
renegotiate the the debt ceiling and and
either suspend it or raise it all right
so let's talk about how Social Security
payments potentially work into this
where does the money come from that
winds up in people's Social Security
checks the way that social security
is paid for ostensibly is that they
collect a payroll tax and everybody's
familiar with income tax we all play pay
income tax but we also pay payroll tax
and it's a 12.4 percent tax usually the
employee pays half and the employer pays
half and it's up to 160
000 or so and change in in compensation
so that 12.4 percent is levied on up to
a hundred and sixty thousand dollars in
compensation if you make more you only
pay the tax on on that uh up to 160 000.
and so that money it's the payroll tax
um is set aside for Social Security So
currently
um that money basically
um pays for almost all the benefits that
go out so you know in theory you would
think that that would mean that you know
in the event that the government can't
borrow it doesn't really matter to
Social Security because it's it's fully
almost fully funded by payroll tax but
in reality the way the government
actually pays those benefits is is
completely different the payroll tax is
the kind of the way they account for
Social Security expenditures but it's
not the way they actually pay them yeah
so what's the money flow here if the
government can't borrow anymore albeit
temporarily
how would that affect people receiving
their checks the fact that the
government may be prevented from
borrowing more money if they don't raise
the debt ceiling would actually affect
social security benefits because the the
way that the government actually pays
those benefits is it has something
called a general fund which is the
treasury Department does which is
basically sort of a massive checking
account for the federal government and
so
um what happens is that most if not all
the federal government's bills flow
through that account and as income tax
revenue payroll tax revenue and
borrowing and other sources of funds
come into the government's coffers they
flow through that general account too so
the government has what they have said
is that they pay their bills as they
come due so on a given day if Social
Security checks are scheduled to go out
that will be one of many bills that are
in line to be paid on that particular
day and if they can't borrow then that
means that the government over the
course of a year can only if without
borrowing they're only going to be
taking in enough Revenue to cover 80
percent of their bills so that means on
any given day on average they're only
going to be able to pay 80 percent of
the bills that they owe so you know it's
possible that that some things are going
to be held over and delayed is there any
Social Security money in any kind of a
side account where the government could
tap into it to prevent any sort of
break-in payments social security has
been actually running
um or for years ran a surplus so it
built up a surplus account it's known as
the Social Security trust fund and
there's I think there's about 2.8
trillion dollars in that account right
now some people think that the
government could actually raid that
account in order to finance and pay
social security checks if they do have a
problem with the debt ceiling and cannot
borrow in order to finance everything
other people disagree so it's it's
really uh as far as I could tell it's
not there's no clear answer on that now
a moment ago you mentioned that one
scenario could be the government only
can pay 80 percent of Social Security
benefits if in fact there's some sort of
an impasse over the debt ceiling in
Washington no politician wants to have
their fingerprints on anyone having a
break in their social security benefits
well so first of all it's not clear that
they would only pay 80 percent of Social
Security benefits I think in 2011 when
we came close to having a problem like
this the discussion was that the
government would wait until they had
adequate money come in to meet each bill
as it came due so it might not be
cutting the you know cutting back on
payments by 20 what it might mean is
that you know in order to get your full
social security check that the check
will be delayed you know and initially
the delays would be probably pretty
short but then if this is goes on over
time you could experience longer delays
so it seems like at least to the extent
that people are speculating on this that
they're speculating there will be delays
rather than cuts and benefits so any
other Solutions on the table it's very
unclear what they're talking about
behind closed doors but in the past in
1996 uh to breaching the debt limit uh
Social Security checks were coming due
very soon and Congress authorized
treasury to go out and borrow the amount
needed in order to pay those Social
Security checks that were coming due
soon and they Exempted that additional
borrowing from the debt limit so some
say congress could do something like
that now that said there was a proposal
there was a bill introduced by a couple
of House Republicans earlier this spring
that would have done exactly that but I
don't think it has the port that it
needs to pass so it's unclear how they
would muster the support to do that at
the moment that was Wall Street Journal
retirement reporter Anne turguson and
that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
foreign